welcome to this video playing iced lemon
tea I knew that I played this guy before
when I wasn't really able to read that
this is iced lemon tea I was really
thinking that this is whatever some
weird language okay we get a Ben Oni had
been only yeah well I can probably still
go with this noisy three set up that I
sometimes play even if he has not yet
committed to e6 now people really love
this maneuver put in the night on c7
it's it's not really create most of the
time but they still do it okay um how do
I go yay for why should I try to do to
to play more forceful like not sure yeah
I can also just just develop first and
see what he's doing good I ok so he
wants to do what exactly I take stakes
be five okay I can still take with the
youporn I don't mind that okay so Bishop
g5 in this position yeah maybe get this
pin going Queen f4 is a really annoying
move if I can play that this is one
reason why the night on c7 that
sometimes questionable because it yeah
it makes it dif more difficult to
support the 90 m
yeah what is this next move
my guess is something like b5 some some
sort of lash out kind of move not sure
if you have something some some passive
move or some pets f is wrong let's say
defensive move by getting Queen f4 I
mean a night before he pretty much is
gone so he needs to do something drastic
maybe a six hour maybe you can afford
still to play a six that takes this time
a 6b 6b five if he goes be five of
course I'm taking it yeah this was also
something that I thought about it looks
so a bit strange but it gets rid of the
pin i want what i do is now I thought of
this before hand I want to control OG
for the night can never go with them and
this means i'm still threatening Queen
f4 and he has no way to go with the
night and maybe ask could have done this
immediately night before i can take
Queen tags and Queen d6 maybe maybe I
should have thought about this huh but
if I go Queen a phone now wait what is
this move where's the night going let's
let's see where is he going don't tell
me you're playing Queen e7 now I mean or
queen d 8 now that play 94 and it's it's
not good h3 really had an idea
I cannot employ 90 area because the rock
is on on the aid yeah that's that's the
sad truth this is sir what you need to
do okay grab here Knight takes I guess
what about or bishop f6 yeah is this
maybe better even yeah this is better i
am night h5 he might have Queen f5
trying to sort of hang on and here I'm
threatening Queen g5 with resignation
and it's still a totally rotten
structure yeah after this I thought f4
would do the trick f 4 98 on night or
rupee a tour to see what is the best
team I assume he has 98 but f1f 498
queen age for rook moves somewhere at
night x h5 looks looks devastating also
98 Queen edge for rookie three rookie
one is also excellent yeah that's
probably best him I still can take age
five and had trade off his rook yeah I
can really take him queen is the man
Christ security protected yeah this was
an opening disaster sometimes if you
play such a borderline opening SI benoni
you cannot afford many bad news and I
think there were some here care tried
this and yeah I'm not really sure what
you should do Queen f voice is quite
substantial once I'm there he's in a
really bad pin
computer wants to wants to lash out
would be five what I what I had
suspected something to 22 yeah get some
type of counter play the stock fish
gives 1.2 idea I can just Eric and
really just take it and go from there
but at least it's it's slightly it
slightly yeah muddying the waters let's
say went here and now yeah 83 i'm not
sure but this is it has this threat
queen air for which she totally not
reacted to rookie one is given by the
comp + 1.5 mm yeah i mean this is simply
a rotten position what is all that okay
age 3 b 6 and this this is this is close
to a win yeah yeah the best move now
computer is rook takes e2 giving an ex
exchange like like simply like that and
here i'm just winning 94 is also strong
plus 6 this is just plus 4 yeah its
it'll win yeah black cannot afford to
play a such a sharp opening and then
misplace your pieces like that if you if
you play that it then there at least
with b5 trying to to yeah to stay up
some trouble this is this way it was
rather easy okay thanks for watching